la michel fize bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors plusieurs éléments
concernant ce projet de loi anti covit
suscite l inquiétude les sages à se
prononcer cet après midi des inquiétudes
légitimes selon vous écoutez je pense
qu'il ya deux cas de figure que l'on
peut probablement exclure à savoir un
rejet total du texte ce qui serait des
juges et le gouvernement et pourrait
apparaître comme un acte d'opposition
politique et de l'autre côté une
acceptation tout aussi totale du texte
je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de
mesures comme cela a été rapporté dans
nos différents reportages qui pose
problème notamment par rapport aux
libertés individuelles
donc on tombe dans la question
effectivement d'une égalité de tous
devant la loi qui pourrait être estimé
contrarier d'une liberté aux soins qui
pourraient être considérés comme non non
réalisés donc je pense que c'est
évidemment des questions de liberté
importante à mettre en face évidemment
du projet gouvernemental d'assurer la
sécurité collective de l'ensemble de la
population mais c'est le conseil
constitutionnel n'a jamais retoqué deux
mesures prises dans le cadre de la crise
sanitaire pourrait tout de même émettre
quelques réserves sur certains points
notamment concernant ce fameux pass
sanitaires et on le voit l'extension du
pass à lithaire provoqua la colère de la
rue
je pense que lepage sanitaire s'expose
un problème d'applicabilité qui va
appliquer la mesure
outre le fait que ce a introduit ce qui
serait chargée de mettre en application
la mesure ça les a introduits dans des
missions de police qui évidemment ne
sont pas ne sont pas les leurs il y a un
problème aussi de détermination à agir
en ce sens je pense tout simplement au
café peut-on imaginer effectivement que
un restaurateur va demander à des
habitués
de son établissement de présenter à
chaque fois qu'il va venir boire un café
le pass sanitaires bon moi je pense que
ça va être très très compliqué même s'il
ya la volonté d'agir en ce sens michel
office vous êtes sociologue et on voit
aujourd'hui ce nouveau mouvement émerger
et celui des antilles passe alors là
vous allez justement évoqué le cas des
professionnels restauration et cafés qui
auraient du mal justement à le mettre en
place d'autres personnes voilà ne
veulent pas se faire vacciner donc
qu'elles n'auront pas de passes annie
terre donc elles ne pourront pas accéder
à ces lieux on voit que ces sont des
protestations qui font beaucoup de bruit
il ya juste qu'une partie de la
population française qui qui soutient
justement ce mouvement selon un dernier
sondage 37 % des français le valide
alors beaucoup disent que c'est peu moi
j'ai envie de dire que c'est déjà
beaucoup 37% des des français qui sont
contre le pass and i ter qui sont
aujourd'hui dans la rue alors qu'on est
en plein été elle savait je crois que
les manifestations de rue moi que je
qualifierais volontiers de
manifestations plébiscite anti emmanuel
macron parce que derrière la
protestation sanitaire il ya également
la protestation sociale
la protestation économique on le voit
bien par la présence constante des
gilets jaunes qui n'ont pas renoncé à
faire s'améliorer la situation sociale
de nombre de français qui encore une
fois reste dans des situations
personnelles extrêmement compliqué donc
ce qu'on voit dans les rues au delà du
sanitaire c'est moins visible sans doute
aujourd'hui c'est toutes ces questions
récurrentes constante posées par le
gilet jaune depuis depuis 2018 et puis
vous le rappeliez dans votre reportage
s'agissant du vaccin la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme avait indiqué il y
a quelques mois qu'une vaccination
obligatoire n'était acceptable qu'à
trois conditions
si le vaccin était connu depuis
longtemps pour apprécier les effets à
moyen ou long terme
ce n'est pas le cas
si les personnes destinataires du vaccin
était simplement des personnes à risque
il ya une possibilité que ce soit pas le
cas non plus et si les sanctions étaient
appropriés et n'était pas
disproportionnée alors on a bien vu que
on est passé des peines de prison et des
amendes très très lourd voilà donc tout
ceci peut susciter l'inquiétude légitime
des manifestants et de l'ensemble des
français qui ne sont pas nécessairement
dans la rue merci beaucoup en tout cas
michel fize avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
sociologue